hi I'm Paul Rudd I'm here with BuzzFeed
and I'm taking the which iconic Paul
Rudd character are you quiz I say iconic
with a grain of salt but it's what it
says
[Music]
starting off question number one how
would your friends describe you these
are these are my choices
kind brave cool funny self-aware lazy I
think all of these apply to some extent
and at other times not to any extent but
I'm going to go with kind because that's
the way I want to be seen number two
choose a celebrity to clone if you could
Jennifer Aniston Tom Holland Oprah Amy
Poehler
Bradley Cooper Paul Rudd well I know one
I'm not going to be cloning I love all
of these people uh yeah I'm going
Poehler gone Amy Poehler the world could
use funny geniuses choose a Marvel
character Captain America Hulk star-lord
Bucky Barnes happy Hogan the wasp boy I
mean I'm on camera talking about Marvel
characters it I think there's really
only one that I could say if I want to
keep my job of these I got to go with
the wasp right she's a true badass I'm
choosing a movie genre now romance
action comedy drama period beasts
science fiction what I I don't know I
tend to like kind of gravitate toward
comedies like if I'm if I'm on a
airplane and I get to watch a movie
usually go look at the comedies first
comedies been very very good to me
and I'm at the comedy if you could live
in any decade which would you choose
60s the 70s the 80s 90s
Ott's or the 21 50s I'm gonna go with
the 60s would have been cool to see all
those great bands the Beatles I would
have liked to God I would I think would
have been cool to be in San Francisco
around that time and you know Woodstock
there was also a lot of social change
and it was a vibrant and vital time I
think it was an optimistic time even
though horrible stuff happened in that
decade I think that people really felt I
think it changed the world in the 60s
and I think it would have been amazing
although it would be nice to say the 21
fifties because that wasn't even sure
that I would make it to choose an app
Twitter Instagram Facebook YouTube
tick-tock chicken wings chicken wings is
an app I get it I get it I myself I'm so
stupid
I almost said the f-word I thought it
was like some new app called chicken
wings hey are you on chicken wings oh
god I gotta put my phone down I just
can't stay off of chicken wings I'm
going YouTube because I'm not on any of
these other ones including chicken wings
but YouTube man I could sit and stay on
YouTube for hours on end and often do
going down the rabbit hole that is news
bloopers
finally finally binge something oh I
should be clicking these shouldn't I
kind
finally binge something is gonna be
tough
binge something on Netflix the Great
British Bake Off
great SEMA seen a lot of them shits
Creek great the office great Jessica
Jones great I haven't actually seen all
the Jessica Jones Black Mirror come on
awesome and glow a terrific show I'm
going shits Creek because I am binging
that currently on Netflix Katharine
O'Hara's character in shits Creek is is
quite possibly the greatest creation
since the Mars rovers it's something to
behold it's it's spectacular and eugene
levy is such an MVP in every category
enlightened but he's just so funny and
the fan the whole family is incredible
as you as we all know you want to know
who I got I'm Bobby Newport from Parks
and Rec like sweetums air Bobby Newport
things tend to come easy for you and
your charming as hell so suck on that
BuzzFeed I'm Bobby Newport vote Newport
come living with yourself and it's on
Netflix here's what I'm gonna say it's
easy to watch it's short thank God and
not a big commitment you can do it in
the night for God's sakes I'm not
telling you to start Game of Thrones but
living in yourself you can watch that
whole show just on the way to the fridge
check it out what's it on Netflix
bye
[Music]
you